all right it's october halloween's
around the corner i think squid game
counts for that halloween vibe a little
bit point is maybe i'm making an excuse
to use my favorite intro but i'm going
to use my favorite intro
[Music]
so squid game is a south korean cinema
series on netflix it's nine episodes
long and the premise is there's this
company person or otherwise entity who
finds
people who are in debt you know people
are just crushed under the weight of
their debt they cannot pay these debts
off they're impoverished they're down on
their luck and they're promised hey you
can get a lot of money pay off all your
debts and then some if you come and play
some games children's games what can go
wrong we all played children's games
when we were kids on the playground well
they're children's games and they're not
told it's life and death but yeah if you
fail the game you die which is a great
premise i heard it's super hyper violent
the thing i appreciate is it is really
violent but again the violence never
felt gratuitous you know it never felt
out of context it all worked for the
premise of the story but it's not just a
bunch of people playing games and that's
entertaining enough it would be
entertaining enough but it goes further
with allegory on classism human nature
money what is money how does it change
you as a person how does it change how
you view other people and what you're
capable of doing to them and it's all
delivered to you in this dish called
squid game this dish that
has the allegory easily digestible but
is also equal parts entertaining great
performances in here too sincere
apologies if i mispronounce any names
lee jung-jae uh he's our lead he's our
guy he's the one that we're behind for
this entire odyssey you can tell from
the get-go that dude isn't everyday guys
he's not like the guy you know the guy
who's clearly going to win this thing no
underdog from the get-go any team he's
in they're the underdog team and we're
fighting life and death here so
everyone's life is on the line he has a
few moments of conflict where it's like
do i go with where i know i'll probably
have a better chance do i do the human
thing and team up with this other person
who also has no shot so they can have a
better shot great human connections in
this story there's one game in
particular
i
i about cry i'm not gonna front i had
the knot in my throat and it's not just
him in that segment in particular that's
when actress ho yung jung she stepped
into the forefront of like oh so she's a
powerhouse in here too all right she's
the quiet pickpocket girl who sits in
the background but no no this game is
one game in particular where they're
dealing with the ugly things they might
have to do
to win the toll it's taken on their soul
is a human the connections they're
forming at this point you know people
aren't just nameless and faceless
opponents anymore
dude this episode binging it with my dad
we binged this entire thing in one
sitting but after that episode i was
like dude that was some heavy [ __ ] he
was like yeah
let's watch the next episode i was all
about like i wanted to take a break i
was like yeah
you know i was gonna drown my tears in a
glass of scotch but [ __ ] it let's do it
it comes from a generation of sterner
stuff where they ate locomotive steal
for breakfast their breakfast beverage
was made from french pressing the ashes
of letters to santa claus but yeah we
pressed on and i love the way this
series wonderfully shows how
it's the high school cafeteria it's the
elementary school cafeteria it's it's
that schoolyard
thought process at first you're like oh
yeah kid games that's you know of course
it'll feel like that but it's not it's
that's human nature you look at how
schoolyard
systems structures friend groups bullies
everything is structured that's that's
human nature at work in its purest form
by lord of the flies is great that's
kind of what this felt like it felt like
an aggregate of a few other stories all
of which i enjoy it's
well i i've heard a lot of hunger games
i'm gonna go ahead and say hunger games
or battle royale whichever one you want
to see it as meets hard target meets
lord of the flies with adults with a bit
of stanley kubrick in there there were
more than a few shots and scenes mixed
with some of the song choice where i was
like this is very kubrick also i love
the fact that these enforcers these
ominously masked people with guns you
don't see their faces you're not
supposed to see their faces but you also
at a point get the feeling like oh
they're slaves to this system too
so who's free and i appreciate any story
that has reveals as you go along where
the reveals are actually hinted at
before the reveals happy you know if
you're paying attention
you can spot some clues that can help
you peel back the layers of okay
i've figured some things out i just
appreciate that where i can go back
watch it again like oh yeah that was
totally hinted at right there i missed
it i suppose if it was one human being
doing it in life it'd be arrogance if
it's cleverly executed in the show
that's just good writing in the end this
show worked on every level that i can
think of great acting great characters
great human depth and relationships
among the characters the games were
absurdly entertaining the blood factor
and carnage again entertaining in that
gory satisfaction kind of way but also
never cease to be disturbing and i
cannot talk about the tension in this
show enough the tension was top-notch
you need tension in a premise like this
some episodes i held my breath for five
minutes other episodes 45 i'm amazed i
didn't pass out in the end we have a
great show about the core of humanity
that should be making american hollywood
sweat right about now after paris had
one best picture i was hoping that south
korean films would get more exposure
here in the us you know like more
releases would come over here and it
looks like that is starting to happen
and squid game is not the only testament
it's not just like squid game and
parasite and they're two anomalies no
there's a lot of south korean cinema
that is [ __ ] great and a lot of us
over here just don't know about it like
i will hear
about the smallest u.s release before i
hear about the next big south korean
release it's kind of how it just happens
over here so i'm glad more south korean
cinema is getting more exposure over
here all right so squid game have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and dad if you're watching
you've been two and a half months
without a cigarette i'm proud of you you
got this and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you